hello and welcome to this intelligent
squared podcast with me carmilla i'm
delighted to welcome our guest today
max brooks um he has a really diverse
career actually he's an actor
voice artist think tanker war
gamer um and author most lastly of the
uh novel devolution a story that
explores
how what happens to humanity when it's
forced into social isolation
very warm welcome to umass thank you
good to be here
all right well let's talk about the
story first
so could you could you bring us into the
community of green lock what's it like
yes well first let me just to the uk
audience
do a massive pre-apology to the scottish
community
uh for the title um
it was a title i came up with many many
years ago when it was
uh when it was being sold as a movie
screenplay
my british publisher begged me to try to
find another title
uh we couldn't so that is that is my
failure and i and i do not need to
confuse
anyone with scottish political
independence
excuse me um the story
the story centers on the high-tech
high-end
community uh of green loop it is a
teller
telecommuter community set in the
cascade mountains in the united states
pacific northwest
and it is supposed to be the ultimate
embodiment of the green revolution
saving the planet through technology so
the idea is that this is a small bedroom
community
where people can live as if they're
living in new york city
they get up in the morning they tell a
commute to work they tap on their phones
about what kind of
uh fresh lunch that they want then they
go for a beautiful walk in the woods the
pristine wilderness
and when they come home a drone has
delivered it from seattle
so this is solar panels this is uh
biogas to to cook their tea
converted from their own feces it's a
wonderful idea
and it works until one day it doesn't
when the volcano mount rainier erupts
and cuts them off from civilization
and because the volcano blows out in the
direction of seattle causing the
greatest natural disaster in american
history
these people are not only cut off
they're completely forgotten
and winter's coming and these very well
paid
very well educated
intellectuals don't know how to change a
light bulb
so they need to dig in and try to figure
out how to work with their hands and
survive the winter
and if that's not the worst of their
problems the eruption has driven
a pack of very large very hungry
sasquatch creatures out of their
traditional foraging grounds
and they need to stack up on calories as
well
and they come up against green loot
which to them
is essentially a pen of sheep and that
is where our story
begins and okay so we've got this kind
of
hyper technological green revolution
ideal
of a society that that suddenly falls
apart what
why did you kind of decide to kind of
focus on that
um you know you're trying to foreground
of
of course the kind of society which so
many different forces are pulling us
towards the moment
yes and i focused on uh
solutions through technology for two
reasons and number one particularly in
the united states we worship technology
because it's the backbone of our economy
but we're always looking for a techno
fix in the u.s
but because of my work with two
different think tanks i've been able to
go deep into the technology world
and understand their culture and there
is no backup plan
there is no redundancy there is no
thought put into what if all this
technology fails what do we do
then and that's always been
a fascination and a fear for me so i
wanted to illustrate what would happen
when this technological utopia fails and
these people are utterly unprepared
and the sasquatches i mean
is this covid are these are these simply
predatory humans
because of course like we're moving now
i suppose from the literal story into
the kind of i suppose
the metaphor or the allegory that you
want to draw from it
you know i was not uh obviously i wasn't
planning on covid because i wrote it
before covid
uh but i was planning on sort of a
general
disaster because in disaster violence is
inevitable
and the idea of being unprepared
not just for starvation for accidents
for infection
for all just the regular threads that
hold society together but also being
prepared
to physically defend yourself uh i think
it's sort of always on the mind
certainly
on anyone who lives in los angeles
because we are probably the least
prepared city on planet earth
and as you as you kind of um explore
this kind of thought experiment
through through a green loop like how
how well do they do
kind of what did what what what do the
green loopers kind of
what are they good at and what they bad
at as they try and fend for themselves
well i think it it all comes down to
adaptation which is pretty much the
theme of
every single book i write and i think if
you were to look at my body of work
just on the surface you would think well
that's a rather eclectic writer i mean
i've written about
sasquatch and zombies also world war one
and even minecraft
uh but underneath them all is a very
continuous premise which is my
characters are living their lives
in life as they know it and suddenly
life changes and they must change with
it or they will not survive and so
in evolution it is a race to see who can
adapt
or die some adapt some die
and and and they're another is the stark
choice facing lots of us but but what's
in what's interesting to me about that
max is that
in one way you've decided to focus on a
society which is probably more adaptive
to the current
kind of economic kind of mores than
anyone else i mean
these the people that live in green loop
they they are perfect
products of a kind of data-driven remote
working age aren't they and it's exactly
that adaptation which has caused them
i think in your argument to be to be
more vulnerable than anyone else at the
same time yes
yeah they are they are the modern
american
equivalent of the upstairs family in
downton abbey
but but does that kind of does it follow
then that what you're saying is that
we're adapting in the wrong way
so so we're adapting in ways whether
it's kind of hyper connectedness or the
skills that we're developing
or or all the kind of like qualities i
suppose in a way that that we're kind of
um adopting as a society these these
aren't the things that are going to make
us
survive the onset of the susquehanna yes
no and this is something i always have
to i always have to be absolutely clear
in every talk i've ever got
done i'm not a luddite i do not believe
that we should go back to
some sort of idyllic quasi-medieval
existence
i believe in technology uh we need it
it's it's critical and i believe we must
go forward but we must go forward with
our eyes open with an eye to what
happens when we stumble
and i think that that's critical and i
think that
uh the british for hundreds of years
were very clear on this
because you had a cultural worship of
your navy
and not just because your tall sailing
ships looked good it was literally
because
without them you would starve so there
was this idea that we can we can have
our tea and our cream on our
strawberries
however there will come times when this
island will suddenly feel like an island
and we are going to need those boats to
keep us fed
indeed um all right max let's turn to
the
this theme of disaster and resilience so
so what fascinates you because so much
of your work i think is really about
disaster and and
be they zombies or or sasquatches or
anything else
what keeps drawing you back to that is
something that you want to continue to
think about
i'm always fascinated by what can go
wrong because even as a child
i saw things go wrong uh i saw the
grown-ups that i depended on for my very
life
show themselves to be human and to make
mistakes
and i sort of never had that golden age
that i guess other people talk about
when you're young and feeling invincible
i never did i always knew that that
death and disaster was always lurking
part of that comes from growing up in
los angeles in the 1980s
you know we've always had earthquakes
we've always had horrible fires
we've always had uh we especially in the
80s we had crime we had drugs
crack uh gangs random shootings an
entire neighborhood i used to
hang out at every day or every weekend
there was one gang shooting and it
suddenly closed and died overnight it's
never recovered
so there was always a sense of things
could go wrong so okay what do we do
and my mother was very good at that we
we had an earthquake kit
we had an earthquake plan we didn't
obsess on it we didn't talk about it
every day
but you know once a year there was time
to go through the earthquake kit and see
what was expired
and and go through the plan what happens
if we're cut off
what do we do and that's sort of how
i've always lived my life and i've taken
that template
to nations you know what do we do
when things don't go well and in my 20s
in the 1990s
i saw a very dangerous trend as the cold
war ended
we believed it was it was what francis
fukuyama the historian called the end of
history
that suddenly the great challenges were
over and we would all come together in
sort of a starfleet united federation
of planets and so there was no need for
redundancy anymore there was no need for
emergency systems
and and taxes to fund those emergency
systems
don't worry about it and we've been
going on that path for the longest time
and now we see what's happened certainly
with covid uh in my country i
expected that you know americans are
supposed to be at least in the beginning
of every crisis
selfish and stupid and scrambling to
adapt
i was rather shocked what happened in
your country
and certainly now that these new
allegations where one of your highest
government officials
said well i think we know we are truly
you know what yeah well let's let's move
to kobe in a second
but we're just staying out there in the
the balmy waters of california for a
second max and
how do you kind of view the kind of
preppers
because i think many british listeners
might be unfamiliar with the
subculture but but it's a kind of
distinct world in the states isn't it
the idea that
actually it's down to the individuals to
kind of look after themselves
in the wake of a disaster yes and that
is absolutely wrong
and i have a lot of fans in the prepper
community which i'm always
battling with them and telling them
you're absolutely wrong
the solution to keeping you and your
family alive is not to sort of move into
the wilderness and dig yourself a bunker
and surround yourself with beans and
bandages and bullets
the solution to keeping yourself alive
is to yes have an emergency disaster kit
for 36 to 72 hours
to keep yourself going until the system
kicks back in
but the long term survival strategy is
to invest in those systems
i was literally on one of our our cable
news programs where the presenter tried
to interview me
to try to coax me to say we should all
bunker down and he had just interviewed
preppers one guy had literally talked
about how he had spent years
digging himself an emergency tunnel and
i said
uh basically that idiot's time would be
a lot better spent
if instead of digging a tunnel he had
run for public office and won a seat on
the city council
and had used all that time and energy to
beef up his town's emergency support
systems
so the lights do stay on and the water
does keep running
because as individuals we do not survive
we simply cannot
this and that's another failure of
popular culture
this sort of heroic notion of the
individual survivalist
because the bottom line is you simply
can't anybody who thinks that they're
going to rise from the ashes like mad
max
and become the alpha male they always
wish they wanted
should look at the average life of a
somali warlord because you simply
cannot survive as an individual what we
need
what's gotten us to this point is what's
called specialization
different individuals working very hard
at one specific task
all the time and then those individuals
coming together
to share their skills to form society
and keeping that network going is how
we've risen from the caves
to be able to talk across the atlantic
on zoom
that's fascinating because the there's a
it's a rare zombie movie
where government itself just effectively
resort
responds to the zombie threat and
everyone you know everyone goes back to
life as normal isn't it
it is always about individuals kind of
rising up
you know out of the chaos and rescue yes
exactly and that's why in my book world
war zed we can say zedd
uh the hero is everybody the hero is
everyone coming together and doing their
part
as they have done in crisis you know
world war ii was not won
by by individual heroes it was one
by all of us doing what we had to do
uh the same thing in plagues the same
thing in natural disasters there's never
one guy with really great hair and
washboard abs running around saving the
world
uh it's all of us and it's and it's
boring and
gritty and it's the daily grind of it as
american gi's used to say
uh we got a job to do so
when you're you're you know your plea
for we need more redundancy in the
system we need to
think about resilience make it more
central is that
ultimately a plea that you're making to
government local and national
governments
you know yes it's sovereign entities
that really have to
do this well it's a plea to us because
in the democratic system we are the
government
we have no one to blame but ourselves
you know i i think that
uh in autocratic systems the people are
just passengers they are completely
innocent
but in our systems uh we vote
and it is our job to be informed voters
and it is our job to seek out news
sources
that we trust so we can be informed
voters and if that doesn't happen
ultimately our president harry truman
used to have a
slogan on his desk that said the buck
stops here well i disagree with harry
trum
the buck stops with me i am a taxpayer
i'm a citizen
and if my government is to use your
terminology
cocking things up well i should take a
look a good hard look in the mirror
because it's ultimately my fault
how much of this you know resilience
thinking and planning
and contingency testing happens within
the kind of policy communities say
either in london or
or dc you know is this kind of a
creature of the think tanks and of the
kind of sakura cracks and the civil
servants
well here this is this is the thing is
that it starts with them
but what used to happen was you had
another link in the chain
that would connect the thinkocrats to
the average schmucks like me
and that was the communication class
that was
government depending on good talkers
who were able to take this sort of very
wonky
policy and put it in language that
people like me could understand
and we did that churchill himself was
such a great orator
so he was able to speak in
simple ideas and the british government
was brilliant in world war ii
hiring these people i i've seen a
wonderful wonderful footage of sir
lawrence olivier who was royal naval
reserve volunteer
possibly the worst pilot in the history
of aviation
but the british government was smart
enough to take him out of the cockpit
and put him on the stage still in
uniform and
explain to the british people here's why
you've got to grow carrots in your
backyard
and we did the same thing in the united
states we took all of hollywood
you know even walt disney who had to be
dragged kicking and screaming because he
loved hitler
and say oh all right i guess we're at
war with hitler i'm going to have to
switch
and explain to us
literally why we fight and we've lost
that we've lost that
that middle link and unfortunately we've
left the communication
to the internet and to anybody with a
podcast
uh who are able to say whatever they
want
and spread misinformation and so
that middle link needs to be reclaimed
because i i
the thinkocrats are still there and i
know them and i've worked with them but
they're constantly frustrated by the
fact that
they'll spend all day tearing their hair
out trying to keep us safe
and then they'll go back home turn on
the tv
and there will be there will be nothing
of what they've said
coming out to the voters do you think
that's kind of
likely to be one of the actually good
things that comes out of kovitz
is is the kind of politicization of
these questions of you know disaster
planning and
and and you know um the creation of
redundant and resilient systems you know
is
are we going to see political parties
coming up with different platforms and
you know this this suddenly becoming and
you know an element of kind of public
debate at the political level rather
than just being something that's left
the kind of
officials to sort out kind of um you
know in the
quiet corridors of power that is the
hope
that is the hope i think you know i
think in life
uh it's not what happens to us it's what
we learn from what happens to us
i mean i'm sure i'm sure in your life
you've seen people go through
crazy experiences that should have
changed their life and should have
taught them experiences and they didn't
learn a damn thing you know they kept
going along
uh and it can be the same thing in
governments you know the united states
we're masters at that uh we should have
come out of the vietnam war
with the greatest counter-insurgency
school the world has ever seen but we
didn't we we literally called vietnam
our great national nightmare
which was something you could wake up
from and then move on with your life
and then when iraq and afghanistan
happen we had to learn those same
lessons over
and a lot of kids died so what my hope
is
is that we come out of this
understanding that not only do we need
to reinvest in resilience
but we also need to reinvest in good
policy communication
so let's look at that toolkit then that
kind of universe of possible solutions
because
you've mentioned a lot and i'm keen to
zero in on exactly what you mean we've
got kind of resilience and redundancy
and investment and infrastructural stuff
um
and let's focus this on on max on where
you
think the pandemic response went so
wrong
um was it primarily in the kind of
preparedness of all of this
is this kind of an issue that you know
should have been sorted out
a decade ago yes was it in the kind of
decision making actually in the middle
of the
pandemic itself i think it comes down to
one word
greed it simply comes down to our greed
uh i saw in the 90s certainly in the
united states how we started to
dismantle our safety network because it
costs
money we didn't have enough medical
equipment stockpiled and there's a very
simple reason for that was in the 1990s
we got rid of all our cold war
stockpiles our warehouses that were
pre-positioned all over the country
because it was expensive to warehouse
equipment and we farmed that out to the
private
sector the problem is the private sector
can't afford to warehouse equipment you
need to turn your stock over so they're
operating on razor thin margins
i literally years before kovid was
sitting in a meeting in washington dc
listening to an expert saying that masks
and rubber gloves are not available in
this country because they are being made
in cheap sweatshops overseas and god
forbid the pandemic starts overseas
we're going to have a shortage and that
came to pass
so that's one thing but also let's
specifically look at china which is a
dictatorship which is an autocracy
which uh suppressed the truth
right this got out because of xi jinping
and his cronies
sat on it and said we got this we got
this we got this we don't got this
now if we weren't so heavily invested
in their slave labor sweatshops making
cheap stuff that we are all addicted to
we wouldn't have stood for that
if this was happening in a country that
we weren't uh economically beholden to
we would have said absolutely not we are
getting in there and we are finding out
what is going on before you
kill millions of people around the world
but we didn't
we said well hey don't want to mess with
disneyland and iphones
so it is it is our own greed
that has allowed so many of our citizens
to die
does all of this equate to and with five
minutes left let me
let me ask you the most complex and
difficult and general question of all
does all this equate to
the realization that liberal capitalist
are also the least resilient in the way
that
a lot of what we've been talking about
the economic forces
kind of like really do point in that
direction you know they're both
creating communities like green loop but
then also
kind of agitating against the kind of
interventions which are required to
actually properly invest in resilient
response yes not at all absolutely not i
would argue the total opposite that
liberal capitalist democratic societies
are the most resilient
because they have the ability to
self-correct
they have the ability to crash into a
problem
demand that their leaders take action
and if their leaders don't take the
right action
you throw the bombs out we did this in
our country
if you look at the coveted response in
the people's republic of china
and the united states the chinese people
are still stuck with xi jinping and if
another plague
breaks out in china oh well there's
nothing they can do about it
we threw that ass clown out because he
was doing such a bad job
and if anybody questions the idea of how
liberal democratic societies
can weather a crisis in the early stages
forget
adapting look no further than the
country that china wants to disappear
which is taiwan that is as democratic as
the uk
or the u.s free press open government
and look how well they've done they've
had a little spike recently but their
spike is
nothing compared to what's happened
around the rest of the world
and why did they do it because their
citizens
understood their responsibility as
citizens
they all understood that hey we live in
a democracy which means
we all got to do our part so we all got
to wear masks we all got to stay away
from each other
we all got a job to do and they did it
and look how well they've done so
that completely kicks the chinese
the people's republic of china their
model in the bollocks
because their message coming out of
kovitt is look how
well autocracies work you know we get to
build hospitals in 10 days
we get to weld people in their
apartments we get to lock people up
you know go with our model give up your
human rights and we'll keep you alive
which is ridiculous taiwan has
completely destroyed that model and if
we all model our democracies
on just being good citizens like taiwan
we will be okay
okay grant okay point taking very very
well-made mess about about the kind of
adaptivity of of democracies
um uh but
but let's focus on the other bit the the
international capitalism
so also a lot of what you've kind of
been talking about you know the
the fact that there is a large
differentiation of
of of manufacturing capability around
the world
specialization of labor um pressure
pressures on public budgets and um you
know i i
constantly to try and drive down tax
basis you know
these are whether you've got a one party
system or many
those are attributes which citizens of
capitalist societies around the world
would all recognize
um where does where does the as an
economic system fit do you think
uh in um um kind of
a kind of spectrum of resilient to
vulnerable capitalism is
i think one of the greatest tools of
freedom ever created because
not only am i a voter i am a customer
i have power and with capitalism
comes competition now don't confuse
capitalism with crony capitalism and
monopolies
you know where one company owns
everything and then you don't have a
choice
but with that wonderful two pillars of
the vote and the wallet
i am able to choose which company
that i want to support and through the
vote i am able
to make sure that i have a choice of
companies
that one company doesn't swallow
everything up now this is
this is why there's been resistance to
these this two
pillar system it takes homework
as a as a citizen as a voter as a
customer
i then have to stay informed and i have
to do my job and i have to make sure oh
uh is the iphone that i'm buying made
in a slave labor camp in china
and is the money i'm giving to apple
making sure that xi jinping
can threaten doctors oh well then maybe
i should look around for another phone
and if there isn't another phone if
they're all made in china then i've got
to do my part
to make sure that other companies build
other phones
in other places so yes it is
it is difficult it is frustrating but it
is the best way for us to ensure our
own safety so it sounds like
um as we come out of the well fingers
crossed we come out of the pandemic now
max like kind of
the the first onus that you're placing
here is on us
as voters and consumers to vote in
you know to vote in different kinds of
leaders and to make different kinds of
purchasing decisions
is that is that right that's exactly
right and that's one of the reasons i
write the books that i write
because i found what this goes back to
what i said about the gap in the
communication class
the talkers the people who can inform
the public
uh that's where fiction science fiction
or horror can come in
because once you've got the audience's
attention once
you're taking them on a fun exciting
ride of a story
educate them that's what happened to me
when i was a kid every episode of star
trek
uh all like the tom clancy books i used
to read they educated me
about the world i lived in so you can
entertain and educate at the same time
and so what i try to do whether it's
sasquatch or zombies or minecraft
i'm trying to mix a little bit of
intellectual nutrition
in with the sugar of the fun ride
and do you see yourself as kind of
in your own kind of work max like
basically trying to
rejuvenate and recover this
communications
layer between people and an official dom
that's concerned about resilience
it sounds like a lot what you're trying
to do whether it's um whether it's kind
of more think tank work or
the app or books that you write really
is trying to kind of throw
ish serious discussions and issues of
resilience and
redundancy into the public to try and
get more people thinking and talking
about
it yes i think that's what i'm trying to
do
lord knows if i'm going to be if i if
i've been successful i'll far i'll
be successful but i gotta try you know i
was just on another british podcast a
little while ago talking about
vaccinations
and they had a philosophy professor on
who'd written a book on how to inoculate
yourself from propaganda
and i thought who is gonna read this
book
other than people who are already on
board what what you're gonna go to
you're gonna go to a biker bar in
lexington kentucky and pass out the book
no you gotta you gotta go to people
where they live
you gotta go to them and so
that's why i'm trying to reach people on
that level
and as we round down i'll say that i am
i am not a great intellectual i grew up
with this crippling
learning disability called dyslexia so i
had to fight in school every single day
and try to make what i was learning
digestible for my brain
so i know exactly how people feel so i'm
i have i can't afford to be a snob
i have to go to them because i sure the
hell wish somebody would have come to me
okay well final question now max and and
i guess this is
the the the really the center of
everything we've been talking about as
as this communications layer what is the
kind of question i suppose you're going
to hope that
the voting public whether in the u.s or
the uk is going to
specifically ask their leaders in me in
in the year ahead
like what you know how do you want to
see the political environment change
yeah i i hope that voters will
will mercilessly grill their politicians
about the systems that keep them alive
especially now especially now with
brexit
you know now that you've gone back to
being an island i i hope that everyone
will
question their politicians and say hey
how are you going to keep my lights on
and the water running how do you keep
the lights on how do you keep the water
running
i used to get all this great fresh
fruits and vegetables from spain
where's it gonna come from you know what
what are the systems the ships the
planes the infrastructure
uh the communications i know that
britain wants
5g and they're going for chinese 5g
because it's cheaper than american 5g
fair enough uh is that 5g hackable by
the chinese government
are there systems built in where you can
spy on me
i demand as a british citizen
to know how all these systems are being
maintained
who's running them and how my precious
pounds are being spent
to maintain them well max
let's leave it there thank you so much
thanks for everyone for listening to
thanks for tuning in this has been max
brooks author of devolution
uh i've been carmilla and this has been
intelligent squared